George Santos is going to serve on two
committees in the House of
Representatives on behalf of the
Republican conference they will be the
small business committee and the space
science and technology committees and I
actually just caught up with the house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy a few minutes ago
as he was leaving the Capitol he
confirmed to me our reports about The
Santos committee assignments and yeah so
he's going to be on committees this guy
who has lied about everything scammed
people stolen money lied about inventing
carbon capture technology lied about
being Jewish lied to everything
he gets committee assignments